[Music]
previously on TV since some serious iron
is you like that thank you just because
the apocalypse is here doesn't mean you
can't look and feel your best
[Music]
getting back into your childhood town
you haven't visited because of sad
memories and immediately going to a
graveyard cliche torching okay riccati
the only thing more fake than john boys
acting is this single tear that not only
appears out of nowhere fully formed but
will remain fully undisturbed throughout
this entire scene this is obviously
meant to reference Stan but how is that
possible Stan killed himself outside of
the town since when can Pennywise see
outside Derek Jesus how much staff does
this small town library neat there are
more personnel than books here occurred
to me in there that I didn't need to
create any more paranoia than we already
have here I got a taste of it myself
earlier meaning that you saw a penny
wise right shortly after you got to town
right isn't that something you should
tell my kid sighs bill says the adults
forget even the ones in dairy and that
[ __ ] was apparently the expert
on it story also this isn't just memory
loss it's full-blown dairy dementia is
this a feature of the conflict with it
or did they all have a highly specific
geographical stroke that was some kind
of force guiding us that summer and I
bet that supernatural force that made
the losers the first humans to ever beat
it will be fully explained by the end of
the miniseries culture I mean they do
have a library books he stepped out of
show while ago Richie's a pretty famous
comedian right then no one recognizes
him he's from Derry and they've already
shown to have pride in one of their own
attaining success a little young for you
Angie Richie you can tell something has
an age well when it's the presumed
psychopathic killer alien morph creature
currently shaped as a clown that's
making the most sense about sexual
morals Richie this is also what Penny
Wong said to Richie in the school
basement but makes no sense if you
haven't read the book so much of this is
just Easter eggs that leave 90% of your
viewers confused like this bike for
instance unless you've heard the book it
means absolutely nothing other than hey
Mike kept an old bike that's weird
YouTube comments about cinemasins staff
a phone call that Dicer makes to me at
least once a week somehow I made its way
into this movie he doesn't think I know
it's him but I do we all can do yes
that's much more efficient than opening
the actual car door and getting in like
a normal human being yeah it's nice to
forget you flew all the way here from
England to help stop the supernatural
serial killings of children isn't it
you're breaking up Fran I can't I'll
call you from the hotel ah 1990 when
rich people overpaid for cellular phones
and personal digital assistants instead
of overpaying for a single device that
does both we will find out shortly that
this is not a penny wise induced
hallucination and Ben is actually
witnessing this kid being chased by
bullies which causes him to flashback
that convenience lies somewhere between
Holi and this miniseries is but doesn't
want any of them here why did he leave
Mike the picture of Georgie jeez Bev the
makeup department did the best they
could give him a break like 1990 and
Rick Baker wasn't born until 1950 okay
I'm with that then this makeup job sucks
you know for all his murderous faults
penny whines is pretty good at being a
clown this truck has plenty of time to
at least brake and slow down but instead
just keeps barreling a bit until the
last second dairy drivers are [ __ ]
Greco I didn't ask you over to insult
field Oh dad we now interrupt the killer
clown stuff you found a tad interesting
to bring you five minutes of a side plot
involving bills wife we briefly met for
10 seconds about an hour and a half ago
because the miniseries we'll need to
convince us she's important when we see
her again in another hour
also Audra has a weird obsession of
being around men with terrible ponytails
okay so it's been a while since I've had
a landline and this takes place in a
different country but did she just dial
four numbers as a full phone number does
that compute yes I'd like a seat on your
next flight to the United States
anywhere will do San Diego sure that's
pretty close to Derry Maine right what a
bunch of handsome old men many serious
stumbles into the eventual tagline for
oceans 14 did people kiss their friends
like this in 1990 I'm not sure it's a
sin if we did sin if we didn't or sin
that we don't need more but it's
definitely a sin one way or another
and it roll clown virtuals I remember
when they pulled him out his hair it
turned white
I'm not sure which is more sin worthy
this overly expositional dinner or the
dairy go around editing let's just add
15 cents for this nausea-inducing dinner
and move on and the morning I get on a
plane and I'm out of here
Ritchie flew all the way from King Los
Angeles to Derry to fulfill his end of
the pact he's only gonna stay one night
and bounce
seems like if this was gonna happen it
would have happened when he had his head
on the toilet back at home Cookie
Monster no den borough there let's put
him on my Norman hey we'll come up with
the outdated lampung joke names around
here mr. Knight court jester dear Stan
it's been six months and still no word I
don't deserve it I know you got my last
two letters I wrote the addresses on a
perfect the only thing he could think of
to do was to hold his bird book out in
front of him like a shield and say as
loud as he could the names of all the
birds he could remember this works I
need a drink
yeah me too library this ain't mad man
man I don't know about the rest of you
but I am getting really sick of this
place now I will listen to anything
anybody has to say but can we do it
someplace else please yeah but Dave's
world should know that he can get with
anywhere in Derry considering he was
also attacked in the restaurant my mom
gave me that to say to help with you
ain't helped look I know this version of
it is a piece of but the fact that these
characters are such great friends and
can bust each other's balls is fun to
watch and I'm gonna knock ass it off
because I'm feeling generous
I guess the rain and blood that spurts
on them is the stuff only they can see
but that is actual broken glass around
them right you can have to get out of
here you're gonna have to go back to
Derry
if Pennywise can take any form why
wouldn't he take the form of a less
decomposed belt and coaches on the door
tonight man Colchester worst Stephen
King humour I'll take care enjoy sir is
penny wise just manifesting actual
weapons now what the hell I can't this
monster do
[Music]
what if Paltrow better hope so she's
based a whole side business on it this
headline is plural when it should be
possessive and I would think the
literary giant that wrote this source
material will call an epic bulletin on
this assault against proper grammar the
dairy disease lactose intolerance is it
an accident that none of us have kids
it's also an accident that no one has
come into this hotel lobby this entire
evening that you've been talking about
this
I know Dairy small that like staff and
the manager are probably at least a
little curious about only the Barrens
yes kids so penny wise also knew Audra
was coming and would show up at this gas
station and asked for directions to
Derry at this time of night how does
that work exactly
this movie is chaos but instead he just
made fun of me and something inside
snapped I got mad I said coach you coach
track writing sort of sneered at me and
nodded if nothing else this movie has
made me appreciate the acting abilities
of John Ritter everyone else feels like
they just got pulled off the stage of a
neighborhood rendition of our town he
just feels like he belonged bills our
writer I just read horror stories really
because the library is pretty sure high
wire is set in the world of espionage I
cleaned the whole thing up that very
same night scene does not contain a Kira
song I decided if I was ever going to
sleep in this house again I'd have to
know the truth to see if anyone besides
me could see the blood so she's telling
them a story about a thing that happened
to all of them I get that there are
memory lapses but the narrative
structure of this movie is still in
bonkers Mike knows the others are nearby
so is there any particular non story
based reason he's not yelling his head
off right now I'd give all the sins back
and then some if Rob Lowe and Bradley
Whitford walked around the corner right
now while talking politics why is it
doing this why is it so me Twitter the
weirdest thing about dairy is that it
has a hospital that looks like a motel
and a library that looks like someone's
house so is Mike this will they or won't
they both is the most annoying part of
this entire miniseries these [ __ ]
flew in from all over the world and all
they can do after they get here is [ __ ]
about how they need to leave even in
1990 you can't escape the conveniently
time news position I told you it's in
every single movie and TV show ever and
your curse is you will now never
not notice it you're welcome because if
I do I'm going to live with this until I
go on say well the last time you forgot
everything so there's at least a 60/40
chance you'll be just fine and honestly
all of them leaving now would make for a
much better ending than what we actually
get how far out of town are the parents
when they were kids they walk there from
school in minutes flat but now they have
to drive we're all here now guys what
the hell are you gonna do now sing
Kumbaya god damn it you're already all
the way out here so stop acting like
you're not gonna do this
I still say we should have brought a
machine gun discount Bill Hader would be
excellent at TV sins yeah I thought that
was pretty far out of left field - dude
I understand it Pennywise knows the
nightmares of the losers themselves
because he hunted them as kids but how
does he know who bills married to the
camera lingers forever on Richie and
multiple scenes throughout the end of
this miniseries and it's got me
convinced that they wanted to kill
Richie in the final battle but area
Anderson refused because he was such a
big star at the time so they switched it
to Eddie
story like that's gotta be true right I
had no issues getting around this place
as kids who probably didn't even know
how to read a map but as adults they're
pretty much immediately lost they've
made it all the way down to its lair and
that [ __ ] Stu would let them just
leave and does it really expect bill to
take off after making it abundantly
clear that Audra's down here what was
the point of hitting her at all also
wait is it its lair or its lair I don't
know if I'm calling it the lair of it or
if I'm saying it is the lair is it
taking the shape of a camera now because
I can clearly see a shadow on the sewer
wall I could never sleep with somebody
that I didn't love and I've never really
loved anyone
you guys ready asking all the time right
now because I thought we established
that's not gonna happen in this virgin I
mean virgin little giant lair Charlotte
Swift also it's the movie trying to say
that penny wise keeps its victims here
so the physical form can feed on them
later because that doesn't coincide with
what's happened earlier in the movie
where he's clearly attacked and then
pitting off limbs of some of the kids I
think order may be unconscious but
honestly her acting here pretty much
matches her acting in the other parts of
the movie so I'm not a hundred percent
sure
his fists I've seen a lot of movies and
I've seen a lot of final boss battles I
have never seen one where the character
attempted to take the big bad down with
speech therapy lessons I can't say
whether I'm impressed or disturbed this
would give up oh cool she was only
mostly dead there's a big difference
between mostly dead and all dead you
know um are they positive that Eddie's
dead like they don't even want to try to
get him to a hospital like they did with
Mike he doesn't even have any obvious
injuries you would be both man I'm glad
this finishes with the resolution of the
bill and Aundre storyline come on sure
how I could have slept at night
wondering if this crazy couple with zero
chemistry and a total of 10 minutes of
screen time together was going to work
out good night Elizabeth that was some
kind of force guiding us that summer
[Music]
- oh stop me
somebody's hot man yeah I'm just gonna
bash your brains hello hello hello it's
a good idea right it's a good idea when
aagama is sexual slavery up here shop
stuff hey this was really fun we hope
you liked it too
[Music]
okay but this can't be good for the baby
you killed my little brother prepare to
die